recording in progress
and
let's get started
you're going to hear today from Mike Ash
who is the education director Caltech
ctme as
over 25 years of experience in advising
International organizations technology
Innovation and Leadership
he manages the Executive Education
offerings for ctme and collaborates on
the design of their learning programs
such as this one
agendas we're going to cover today will
ask a few questions about you with poll
questions during the presentation
so keep an eye out for those we'll talk
a little bit about cyber security
careers
what this particular program offers you
how it gets you job ready for a career
in cyber security
we'll cover the enrollment steps
and I'll take some of your questions so
if you put those into the Q a
I'll be able to get those uh toward the
end of the session
well
at this point I'm going to have
session re-recorded with Mike a bit
earlier and we will
have him talk about careers in cyber
security
so when we think about cyber security
that you already know what the reason is
that that we need that part of our
perspective and why I think that our
program in Caltech is is different and
also how we thought about this program
when we first put it together is it's
it's not just about
um
securing uh things on the web it's also
about the the networks in the centers
but also more importantly we have to
think about critical infrastructure what
is critical infrastructure uh those are
airports Banks large places where people
can convene uh entertainment it's the
power generation plants
um and all the all these things that
make
life work
um airports uh you know Transportation
uh Communications networks and and so
while there are Bad actors that
that are really just about
um
getting money or and ransomware and and
trying to do things like that or other
types of fraud there's bad actor there
are Bad actors that are either state or
non-state that are just out there just
to create chaos
um and and we've seen that what we've
done in in designing part of this
program is making sure that you have
access to projects
um Technologies uh leading practices and
insights from those kinds of of
vulnerabilities and threats and and how
people have recovered
um
the the program is is really about
creating uh new skills for you uh so you
can join any kind of role and so whether
you're a developer who's looking to move
into a cyber security role or you're an
analyst you haven't been exposed to that
much coding but this is maybe important
uh for you uh you can either shift your
career or jump straight into cyber
security code having a background and in
in coding and analytical uh
tools and processes are are going to be
brought to you through what uh what
we're going to do in this
in this program
in in addition to a number of analytical
skills and coding skills uh we're going
to get into really the thinking behind
uh
the motivations of of Bad actors but
we're going to think analytically about
what creates vulnerabilities what
creates
um I'm just gonna check out the chats
for a second
um
just making sure uh Stuart if we're
answering those along the way
um how do we recognize what are our
leading practices for uh
uh
development and protecting the things
that we have whether it's in embedded
systems or web systems or
um
Control Systems things like that so not
just uh kind of the the stuff that we
just see every day you know it's the
Building Systems the the things you
don't always see
um we'll learn about business practices
such as continuity and Recovery
um uh forensics trying to look at all
the breadcrumbs and evidence and the
facts that lead to
root cause
analysis through root cause analysis
um
and and
trying to put together all the pieces
that really kind of either let you know
something could be going wrong something
did go wrong how did it go wrong and
what is it going to take to fix that
um
let's see just a second
all right so let's move on
so you heard from Mike about careers in
cyber security
okay
that works
yeah we're on the air okay so what
um
what's great about the the questions and
thank you for for taking time to answer
those is it
it kind of confirms some of the things
that we think about uh the programs like
this and how we've designed them
so let's talk about
um
what's stopping you from becoming
a cyber security expert what's prevented
you
in the audience from
engaging in a program of this type
so because you can't find a program that
covers all the kinds of skills that uh
Mike spoke about is it because
you don't feel you'd get
a practical experience you could show
off after the program to demonstrate
your new skills
is it difficulty from learning from
pre-recorded videos or is it finding
time in your schedule
this
question open for another 15 seconds or
so if you get in your answers
see the numbers are still coming in
um
all right and we'll close the poll in
five four
three
two
one
and the major concern for about half of
you is that you don't think that you
would get
practical experience that you could
demonstrate to show off your new skills
um
about a third of you each
are worried about finding a
comprehensive program
and finding one that will fit into your
schedule
but we'll go back and listen
to what Mike has to say about that
there are a lot of classes that are out
there there are a lot of
um
tools that are out there that you can
learn from vendors
and doing that piecemeal
is inefficient you don't get a broader
understanding of the picture you also
don't have often you know people with
broad experience being able to
to help you learn from what they've
learned and our our point of view for
the boot camp programs that we have like
this they are comprehensive in that
not only are we going to cover what we
believe all the things that you need to
understand including
um
uh you know these
uh Security Essentials
um
attacks and and threats and an analysis
and being able to present that analysis
we've got to you've got to do the full
thing and
that doesn't come lightly this is a
six-month program and and the way that
it's structured is it works really well
for
people who are already full-time
employed
so there are pre-recorded videos and
learnings and things that you can do
that are on your own but the the real
value is also when you you come in and
you have live sessions with the
instructors and you are
um you're you're interactive you're
going through the things that that uh
they either they wanted to show you but
also you're demonstrating how you grasp
those tools whether it's through a new
script that you wrote does that work
what uh how far do you get through all
the gates
um and also having your peers and how
the class is organized into teams
having everybody come together and doing
that and a lot of that work happens also
on the weekends so
um the this is a mix of
different modalities
um but it's very participant centered
and you also have access to not only the
platform 24 7 and you can get tech
support uh 24 7 but you have instructors
and Tas
um that you interact with and either can
answer questions or can coach you on the
side whatever your learning preference
really is
um and so it's adaptable like that so
um it is it is comprehensive it is
intensive this is not the easiest cyber
security program
um there will be uh parts of it
especially when you're getting into
understanding
but uh
um Computing Essentials and
understanding how memory works uh you're
going to get into some of the needs
um but we believe that this is a mix
that that's really going to work
for you all
whoops
um
so after the the throughout the program
there are several small projects and
then a Capstone at the very end which is
a larger project that you use to help
demonstrate all the things that you've
learned
um and you can demonstrate and show off
uh code and materials say through GitHub
with potential employers or your sponsor
from your job
but you're also going to get a
certificate from Caltech at the end of
this there is a letter of of completion
that states the number of continuing
educational credits or units that you
get
this program is about 250 hours
you get 26
continuing education units for that
that's a significant amount 250 hours
this is a little long like we said it's
a comprehensive program
um but you also get into a private uh
LinkedIn membership group uh with others
uh that Circle and near the end of the
program if you elect to you can use uh
simply learn and talent inks
career advising services so they'll get
you ready work with you on your resume
work with you on the how to best present
um
new skills in in coding or
uh designer if you were doing the part
of the web design
um but all all these things and really
helped get you prepared to
um
to present uh not only your experience
but your new insights and how you both
either defend or think about
vulnerabilities and threats from an
attacker's point of view right
um there is a online graduation event
that we do with all of our simply
learned programs it occurs about every
quarter
um and there are uh Awards and
um
and and then times that people talk
about the the value of the program that
they just went through and you hear from
other people's experiences and it's
really cool
um
and so one of the things I want to
highlight is also this is a very Project
based course
it's not
theoretical it's not just read the
slides and and you're good this is a
boot camp that's intensive and geared
around projects and things that you have
to complete so there are assignments and
um
that are either Snippets or
actions that you really have to get
through
um
I think you already know who Caltech is
California Institute of Technology we're
in Pasadena California
when we originally started this program
uh we
for those who are in town we wanted to
be able to also take them to the LA
cyber lab
in Los Angeles which is and if we can do
that now that uh we're on the back side
of the pandemic
um it is an integrated uh threat
Response Center uh for for the county
and all the different
um
major uh
operations centers more rooms uh you
know use this as a central Hub to get
out information about attacks and
threats
um and and so if uh if we can spin that
up again that's going to be that's going
to be great
all right
we've heard from Mike and we've had a
couple of questions already about
eligibility and what background you need
to have in order to enroll in this
program
pretty straightforward
um
you need to have basic knowledge of
programming Concepts and math
cyber security
has to do with
encryption coding and that type of thing
so there's some elements of math in
there but you don't have to be an expert
coder or math major
you do have to have a high school
diploma or the equivalent and you need
to be 18 years of age
um do not have to have prior work
experience always helpful to have that
but it's not required for this program
so
this is a pretty straightforward program
Open to almost everybody
and with that I'm going to ask how much
experience
our audience has
just to get a feel
and I will be getting to your questions
later so
we just focus those on the Q a by the
way it's easier for me to track them
there but I'll also look through the
chat
okay
all right and I'll leave the poll open
for another five seconds as you get your
answers in
okay and here you go
so we have about uh a little more than a
third of our audience who are still in
school
if you are in
college or university and have your high
school diploma you are eligible
and then the rest of you have work
experience
some 20 of you over five years so
um
so now I'm going to go into how the
program prepares you
this program has a comprehensive
curriculum
it starts off with the induction which
is just a brief overview class that
shows you how to log into the learning
management system where to find all your
resources what to expect from the live
classes what kind of schedule to expect
from the projects
um all of the basics that you need you
want to get support
once you've done the induction you'll be
ready to start in live classes will
generally be held on the weekends
Saturdays and Sundays four hours each
um
starting with the cyber security
fundamentals course that gives you
an overview and basic grounding in what
cyber security is and what it entails
from that you'll move on to asset and
inventory management
so that you will be able to understand
what all the components are that you
need to protect within your organization
threat surface is that you need to
defend
uh you move into Network systems and
understanding the security aspects
of those
then there will be a module that will
take you into Python Programming so that
you're getting the basic programming
skills that you need in order to
complete the course
move into system administration how to
use the cyber security tools that are
provided for you then in the last two
modules you get to get into
um
practicing both
ethical hacking and penetration testing
for the red team the uh
offensive team trying to break into a
system and you'll also
look at the other side how to defend
from the perspective of the blue team so
you go through all of these modules
and complete the course
and you'll do it all on the live
learning platform so I'm going to let
this gentleman
tell you about that
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make up
our online boot camp approach so
successful great content from the
world's leading technology companies
practitioners and universities and a
unique and proprietary learning
environment that was specifically
designed for high engagement and learner
support when you log into simply learn
you set the course timeline that meets
your busy work and home schedule and
keep track of your progress every step
of the way we'll help you stay on plan
with automated and 24 7 human support at
the core of our programs are our live
virtual classrooms where you interact
Real Time with trainers that are
recognized leaders in their field there
you'll review key Concepts get questions
answered and interact with your peers
the important reports under audience if
you notice our demographics this is
super useful especially if you're
running ads for example you could do it
on social media later you'll learn
social media marketing too
by looking at these numbers you'll be
able to understand the age range of
people that you should be targeting you
know what you could just focus only on
that age category show your
advertisements to them very useful
that's not all you get to learn from
faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes as
ask your questions to top industry
leaders in exclusive ask me anything
sessions so
instruction of Google Trends and
optimize it okay so let's go back to
here right here where it says web
searches and you can see that there's
going to be the YouTube searches okay so
now you can see that the YouTube
searches is going to be so there's a
option uh under not just web search and
there's going to be a YouTube search
okay so just go ahead and click on
YouTube search and you should be able to
optimize your search results
so what is Instagram app Instagram apps
refer to when we come across any sort of
original video
apps would appear within those video
content so you would be taught when you
are watching an original video and leave
you a video app and then go back to the
original video content
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice tackle practical
problems with multiple projects and
simulations and work on a real world
Capstone project that you can showcase
to Future employers your learning isn't
restricted to just live classes explore
our highly effective self-learning
videos and other resources to fine-tune
your learning and remain up to date
always you can focus on different
learning approaches by subject to
personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn so
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
all right so you've seen a an overview
of the learning environment and to recap
you've seen how you can manage the
content in your program and the
different courses As you move through
them
saw the live virtual classroom
environment how to do tests assessments
Labs projects
um an overview of the Capstone and
progress tracking how to keep track of
which courses you've completed which
ones you're eligible to start next
getting certificates along the way and
finally unlocking your
program certificate for
depletion of the entire program so
you have 24 7 support tools for both the
platform itself and for the the course
content and you have access to a peer
community
that you can
turn to your fellow students and ask
questions and get support so
the program advisor and overall director
is uh
Rick
um excuse me
sorry Rick is the the
program director for Caltech ctme he's
he happens to be Mike's boss
and um
he has over 40 years of experience in
the industry
both in academic and Industrial
Endeavor so he's got a very broad
background and understands well how
technology education needs to um support
the needs of of industry for hiring
and uh
upskilling their workers so
learner outcomes
so you
uh encounter people from different
backgrounds as your peers in your your
course people who have come in from
working backgrounds with other companies
like Microsoft Amazon Netflix
and coming in from different Industries
Information Technology software products
but also banking Financial
Health Care Industrial
and a whole wide variety since nearly
every industry that exists
has assets that have to be defended
against cyber security threats
we'll also provide as Mike mentioned a
career assist service that is available
to you for six months after you earn
your certificate
but we provide this through a partner
Talent Inc or Learners in the United
States
and our career service includes their
services the talenting part as well as
the projects that you build for your
portfolio through the program and expert
webinars and career events that simply
learn
provides for free on an ongoing basis
so the career services available to you
for the six months after you complete
your certificate include access to the
resume rabbit job portal which is an
exclusive job portal run by talenting
it's a very confidential
so your current employer won't
see your job search there and it has a
number of exclusive job listings we
think that's a valuable aspect of the
service we think that the other two
parts are even more valuable resume
review and rewrite the top resume
service
is important because today's environment
your resume goes through
an automated AI
screening part of the automated tracking
service you submit it to an employer
whether you submit it digitally or on
paper it will be digitized and run
through an AI bot that will filter it
against
the job description
so your resume needs to be in a format
but the AI bot can easily assimilate and
understand and evaluate
at the same time your resume will end up
if it passes that filter going to a
human being on their desktop or on their
screen
and it still needs to be attractive to
the the human reviewer so
the balancing of those two objectives
AI filtering and the human appeal is
really an art form and that's what the
resume review and rewrite service will
help you with
um similar event with one-on-one
interview service is extremely valuable
because if you pass through the resume
filter and someone calls you and wants
to talk to you
you're going to have to go through a
series of interviews
screening interviews with the HR
department technical interviews with
technical managers of that job
and management interviews with the
hiring manager to talk about your
ability to work as a part of a team
you're fit with their culture
all of those interviews required
slightly different skills and different
ways of presenting yourself and the
one-on-one interview service allows you
to practice those with you
these are all valuable parts of your
job search process
not a job guarantee but a job search
assistance service that helps you with
your job search and helps you to put
your best foot forward mention the
webinars we talk about different
subjects overviews of different sectors
of the industry or we talk about how to
get the most out of a job search or
how to care and feed for your career
and how to plan out what your future
steps should be
and all of these are available to you at
no cost on an ongoing basis
So based on what you've heard from Mike
and me today
are you interested in enrolling in this
program
this one question
now
and since it's a yes or no question
we'll just leave it open for about 20
seconds
another 10 seconds or so
and we'll close it in five four three
two one
uh interesting everyone who responded
said they are interested in enrolling in
the program
so let me share with you
the steps to do that before we get to
our q a
well our enrollment steps are extremely
straightforward you email us at ask us
simplylearn.net and I'm going to
share into the
chat
that email address along with the
link to our program page
so email us at ask us at simplylearn.net
you
we will review your qualifications again
they're very basic you can verify that
you have a high school diploma
and
we'll do a basic test of your aptitude
in programming in mathematics
um just to make sure that you that
bar for entry
and once you do once we've evaluated
that and verified it you'll get an offer
of admission from us
um our
next orientation
behind here my camera's obscuring
um February 9th is our next orientation
and the classes start February 13th so
if you want to hurry up and get into
that uh cohort
by all means do
um email us right away and contact us
about that
um
the program cost is ten thousand dollars
uh you do not have to pay that all up
front we can Finance it for you at zero
percent financing over a 12-month
payment period also if your employer
sponsors your education and does tuition
reimbursement you can contact them
find out what their policies are and
to what extent they can help you with
the cost of the program that would be up
to them not simply learn their Caltech
and um
yeah and please contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net for more information and
get your questions answered
and ask folks
how soon you would be interested in
enrolling something you would want to do
for this
cohort that's coming up next week or is
it something you'd look for doing a bit
further down the road
maybe in March or April
but something
that you want to keep
on tap for future
again I will leave this open for about
five more seconds
here we're going to end the pollen now
and
pretty even distribution about a quarter
category
so if you are interested in starting
in uh
in the February cohort please email us
right away
um if you're interested in March or
April
do the same because we'll need to get
you started soon and if you're looking
further down the road I do go ahead and
email email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net and we will
be able to keep track with you
uh
let you know about future cohorts as
well
oh move on to the questions and answers
don't need to keep staring at the slide
when you
dirt me but I will come up with
some of the questions that we've
had
a question from Patrick
and it's an interesting question
wonders if he's too old
um the from my perspective Patrick
um
I have
over 40 years of experience in the
industry
I do not believe that you are ever too
old to take on a new skill set
um as long as you feel you have uh
future years of uh career to work on
there's no restriction on how old
you can be in order to take this program
and certainly the more experience that
you have in the workplace and in a
domain more value you can provide when
you add cyber security skills to that to
that mix so I do not think
anyone is too old for this program
and certainly it's important to continue
to learn on a lifelong basis in whatever
field you're in
um
had a question about the educational
level I think we covered that
we only have to have a high school
diploma in order to get into this
program
um
let me
move my
is this for California residents only
and the answer to that is no this is
open to um
it's really available to anyone in the
world this particular version of the
program is designed for North America
and Latin America
so you can enroll from anywhere in the
Western Hemisphere
the timing of the classes is based on
that
um but it is in fact possible to enroll
from anywhere in the world this program
um
the one thing I have to say is that only
for people in the United States are the
career services available
um
same user sequence asks is the
certification validation why the
certification is valid worldwide
wherever the name Caltech is recognized
basically it
um
certifies that you have met their
requirements completing their
professional education program so
um
anywhere that you
that people will recognize the name
Caltech and that is really anywhere
around the world
people will recognize that you have
um
gained your set of skills in a rigorous
program
um
can someone without basic knowledge of
cyber security who wishes to start a
career in the field join
and the answer is yes
that is the reason why the first module
in the program it covers the
fundamentals of cyber security
so if you don't have that background it
will give you a grounding in it that you
up to speed
um
outside of the U.S has this program
provided success for international
students uh
yes it has but you'd want to contact ask
us at simplylearn.net to get detailed
information about that and maybe some
testimonials
um and simply learn works with Caltech
on other worldwide programs as well so
um
Patrick asks about experience and what
we talked about experience for uh
it's a program job experience
any job experience Patrick
really understanding how organizations
work from the inside
any capacity
however the course cost price
um
so we have a user who says if you've
taken certified ethical hacking and ocsp
training
do you need to take this program and
that's something you would have to
answer for yourself
um
but
this program will give you
more skills training and more
fundamental understanding as well and
along with exercises and projects that
you do uh to demonstrate your skills so
if you feel comfortable that you have
with your certifications and um
your current experience
um
tools you need to succeed you may not
need this program but if you want to
take a deeper dive into it you should
look into it contact us maybe download
the syllabus from our website and see
whether this is something that will add
value for you uh payment plan payment
plan divides the cost into 12 equal
payments with no interest
uh will there be a link to the recorded
video of this session yes there will be
we'll send that up by email
I
have
a person
GK blankson who says I'm new to Tech my
background is in the social sciences
like the branch into cyber security
um this is a great program for that
because
um
if you're if your question is what
aspect of cyber security would you want
to focus on
this program covers a broad spectrum so
it gives you a well-rounded background
in different aspects of cyber security
and gives you the foundation to make the
decision about
where to specialize
but because you have the broad
background
even after you choose a specialty go
further into that you'll also be able to
interact with your peers and understand
their roles within cyber security as
well so this is a great program
and
what is the next cohort after February
please contact ask us at simplylearn.net
for that we usually run about once a
month or so
um
is this possible for someone in the UK
you can enroll in this program in the UK
I believe there's a edition of this
program
that Caltech and simply learn to offer
or
folks in Europe Middle East Africa and
Asia but um again contact us at ask us
at simplyarn.net you can certainly take
this program as long as you're willing
to
get to the class meetings on the odd
hours U.S schedules
um
does it simply learn offer an income
sharing agreement option we do not
um we offer this program
with Caltech on a
flat fee bases
um
we don't want you to feel like we're
going to
be reaching into your wallet for any
extended period of time after you get
your job
so this is this is not done on that
basis
um I'm going to go into the chat now
because I've looked through the Q a
and
a little more difficult to find the
questions here but I'm going to look
okay
hold on just a moment
getting to them
okay how can database administrators and
Developers
prove to their Auditors that their
organizations are legally compliant
that is an excellent question
there are other along with
this course which talks to a certain
extent about
governance and compliance there are
other courses that we offer but I would
contact ask us at simplylearn.net
to get into that because uh
you
that's a question about
the governance and compliance aspect of
cyber security which is uh
somewhat specialized but it's also
extremely important because as you know
from your position
unless you can
prove that you're compliant
your business is going to be impacted
um
Becca who asks at age of 47 sorry for
revealing your age Becca
am I crazy for crazy for jumping into
cyber security Now not at all
um
if this is something that you have a
passion for
this is a great field it's growing and
anyone who follows the news knows
threats to cyber security are coming
more and more
dire yeah more and more important to the
health and functioning of our economy
personal security of individuals
so cyber security is a very important
and growing field
and the threat surface
number of places where someone can
attack your life
through cyber security
cyber security threats
just keeps getting bigger and bigger as
more and more of Our Lives Move online
so
um
well just a moment
see if I've gotten to the end here
Rachel asks I really want to enroll in
this program I'm studying cyber security
now but I want practice and experience
to build my resume
can you do both or do you need to
graduate before you start with Caltech
it depends on what program you're
currently in Rachel so if you're in a
degree program and
um
it's going to be several years before
you finish
you would have to decide if you can
devote the 10 to 15 hours a week for six
months
to do this program in parallel if you're
close to the end of your program or if
you're in a program that's going to
complete within a couple of few months
then you probably want to wait to finish
that and then look at enrolling in this
one just to make sure that you have the
time to devote to both of them
and
let me see if I've got anything left
here
uh solomay asks a great question does
the fee cover all certifications that
are required I believe it does but you
want to verify that by contacting ask us
it simply .net
uh we got a question about the fees
somebody missed it the program cost is
ten thousand dollars U.S uh and that's
flat and that covers all the questions
we've had so far so I'm going to go
ahead
move to the end of the program
with one
last poll question for our audience
and
with this poll question I'm going to
invite you
let us know if you'd like assistance and
also if you are interested in receiving
a proof of attendance for today's
session this webinar
just a proof of attendance that doesn't
qualify you for
technical skill but it
we will be glad to send you one if you
answer yes here
I'll leave this open for another
five seconds or so since it's just a yes
or no question
four three two
one
well about two-thirds of our audience
are interested
systems with enrollment or receiving a
certificate for today's session
share that with you
and
so with that
I want to say thank you to everyone who
attended here today I really appreciate
your
taking the time and
sharing your interests with us
and on behalf of Caltech ctme and simply
learn we would love to welcome you into
our learning community
with that I'm going to end the webinar
so again thanks everyone for being here
thank you